scientists have revealed the most
detailed 3D map of Mars ever it's like
Google Maps but exclusively for Mars the
map is made out of 110
000 images of the red planet taken by
NASA's reconnaissance Orbiter it's so
detailed that it took over six years to
stitch it together and if you were to
lay it out flat it would be the size of
a football field this map which you can
check out online right now lets you
explore some of the planet's Most
Fascinating locations you can get an up
close look at the largest volcano in our
solar system Olympus Mons check out
jizzero crater and tons more if humans
ever make it to Mars this map will serve
as a guide on our interplanetary journey
are you gonna check it out